hello everybody can everyone hear me so
my name is Eleanor sterling and I'm the
director of the Center
Shin at the American Museum of Natural
History in New York and I have the
pleasure of introducing this wonderful
event this evening and what I'm going to
do is just give a really quick overview
to some of the thoughts and ideas that
we have for today and then introduce a
bunch of other people who will introduce
a bunch of other people because we are
after all in a panel and I should have
asked how to advance the slides so today
we're going to talk about the nexus of
art and science and art science in
nature and basically my argument is that
art and science both navigate to the
relationships between humans and the
world that they live in and they're both
ways of knowing and investigating the
world around us and of understanding our
interactions with nature they're both
also especially pre modern art grounded
in close observation of the natural
world in both art and science we search
for patterns and relationships across
various in sets of information and
knowledge systems from genetic analyses
to binary and operas we will explore
motifs or patterns I don't know if
anybody read the New York Times blog on
that the other day but if you're
interested come ask me about it
afterwards and those patterns are
repeated in various ways in a larger
work art and science both developed
imaginative forms and processes and
solutions that communicate or create new
relationships across disciplines so
these are various ways that in my mind
art and science unite especially over
nature I think I might be doing this
panel because because James is a friend
and he's trying to torture me to know
but also because I taught a class a long
time ago at Columbia University on the
interpretations of nature and I taught
it with a humanist who was looking at
nature in Madagascar from the
perspective an artist and the literature
in Madagascar and then I of course
brought some of the scientific
perspectives and the people in the class
were really didn't get at the beginning
why we thought that you could take
various ways of looking at nature in
Madagascar and and start with art and
move through to scientific papers and
all of them were bankers from New York
and hadn't really read scientific papers
previously and it was really exciting
for us to explore the the critique of ID
is an information to look for evidence
in anything that you're doing in art in
in your scientific arguments to be able
to understand better something so I'm
also supposed to talk a little bit about
how art intersects with the work that I
do at the Museum of Natural History and
of course some of the most obvious ways
that it intersects is with depicting the
animals and plants that we work with
this is a beautiful set of drawings by
Joyce posit from here from Connecticut
who is traded a book on the Vietnam
natural history of by Yale University
Press and so monographs and field guides
are going to hear a little bit more
about field guides later and of course
our iconic dioramas are wonderful
examples of art that people don't even
think about as they're going through the
museum and seeing the natural world
itself interacting these gorgeous
backdrops is another way that science
and art unites in a seamless way we also
use art in our temporary exhibitions i
curated an exhibit on water a couple of
years ago and I insisted that instead of
having some text on the wall that it
talks about the various ways that water
is found on earth in its gaseous solid
and liquid phase we made a sculpture
that kids can interact with to get that
science across that science fact across
and that kind of thing we try to iterate
over and over we also use them Edward
Burtynsky Three Gorges Dam photographs
he's a phenomenal photographer to talk
about some of the water issues and we're
doing an expand I won't tell you exactly
what's in there in terms of art but i
will tell you you're using a lot of art
in that and this is just some of the art
that we explored this is the shanghai
expo from 2010 and Heather works to do
did this amazing building this is a huge
building these are people standing
outside the building and these are all
each one of these is a rod that has
seeds it's called the seed pavilion and
again it's a way to explore art through
various media of art and nature through
the media of science as well as art so
other ways that we work in the museum on
art is through ground landscaping we try
to plant native plants and think about
ways to make that beautiful for the
neighbors who think that native plants
might be just weeds the building
architecture
are the public programs and global
kitchen programs and exploring the
keulen airy arts so lots and lots of
different ways that we feel that art and
science come together in the exploration
of nature there are also a lot of ways
that art and science are divided in our
in our lives and Elizabeth cinnamon
arrow scoffs going to come up and talk
to us a little bit about that she
herself is an artist and a quail farmer
who is going to spend a little time
chatting with us and then also introduce
the panelists so thank you very much for
listening to these introductory remarks
and let's welcome was it if her stuff